let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
happy
420. it's hump day and 420
so i guess you get to uh get roasted and
baked
to make it through the week
good morning robin good morning debbie
from salt lake ken is here kathy is here
midas lisa is here
nancy
we have we have lisa from facebook janie
from facebook patricia from facebook
everyone's here this morning kimberly
good morning nancy good morning
good morning good morning good morning
all
you guys are you guys roasted and
toasted yet it is 4 20 right i mean
so we're gonna get it baked i guess it
depends on which state you're in
and rather you have a a medical
marijuana card or not
i mean some states you don't need
you don't need a prescription but some
you might or a friend
who just may or may not blow shotguns in
your face if they have a prescription so
everyone seems uh
everyone seems baked this morning
everyone's giving thumbs up good morning
everyone welcome to the tony michaels
podcast you know we broadcast here every
single weekday even the ones we get high
on
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific youtube twitter and
twitch and now from the midas touch
facebook page we are on the books
a face
remember go over to youtube and
subscribe to our channel just type in
the tony michaels podcast or tony
michaels podcast
in the search bar on youtube
you'll find us there
also go to go to twitter and follow us
at tony michael's pod you know tomorrow
we will be releasing the bonehead of the
week poll
to see who is the bonehead of the week
we have a lot of boneheads today
there's a congresswoman from arizona who
apparently does not know the difference
between gazillions billions and
trillions and millions i don't know are
thousands even
oh for crying out loud
what a [ __ ] knucklehead
these ninja poop nazis
we're gonna we're going to
we're going to explain why
when the when the border patrol under an
administration whether it's
biden or anyone else apprehends quote
quote-unquote
migrants at the border
that it's they're doing their job
and and also if you if you seize drugs
at the border that's also a success
that they're not getting through the
border
who needs a goddamn wall anyways when
you're
when you're apprehending and arresting
one billion migrants who needs a [ __ ]
wall pew pew pew pew pew pew
i tweeted that this morning we'll get to
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
settle down children we'll get there
we also have boneheads that think disney
is still the antichrist
oh [ __ ] these people and there's videos
from people trying to stop up the disney
line
pissing off all the parents that paid
for their vacations to go
to disney
so that their children can enjoy the
magical world of disneyland
that is
tucked inside a state that is desantis
land holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
talk about a bonehead
ron desantis banning math banning math
in florida
you know it's
makes sense they can't count to a
trillion billion gazillion
quadrillion
you know
they can't figure out how many migrants
are coming across the border
a billion a billion
a [ __ ] billion
oh [ __ ] this is the same way they think
donald trump is a billionaire right
right they can't uh math is [ __ ] hard
happy
happy
happy 420 this is really [ __ ]
ridiculous that we have to
continue to go to this scourge of
stupidity but it is not gonna quit
trumpism is not uh not quite gone yet so
we will have to continue
this nonsense
we got some people and new people
joining us amanda is here
frank from facebook is here
skip is here crystal from facebook is
here good to see you again free crystal
everyone's here this morning holy moly
we got a lot of new listeners
for all you new listeners out there just
to give you an idea we are on the air
live
live streaming kind of like a radio show
you know think of me as your i don't
know let's say
let's say walter cronkite
howard stern
and um let's see who else who else andy
rooney
maybe maybe all three of them screwed
and had a baby maybe that would be me i
don't know i don't know but think of it
as a left-wing talk radio show that
lasts two hours every single weekday
every single weekday the good news is
it's all on video so you don't have to
just listen to it but you can listen to
it
you don't have to look at my beautiful
face to hear my beautiful voice you can
go download it on apple spotify google
all your favorite directories
you can download each and every episode
all two hours every single weekday
monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific is
when we go live
now if you want to listen to it on the
podcast directories no problem
no problem just wait a little bit till
the afternoon till we get it up on the
directories
because we actually have to do the
episode
it records
and then we post it on the directories
but when you're over there on the
directories
whether it's apple spotify google
wherever i heart radio wherever you're
downloading your podcast wherever you
listen to them at make sure you're
giving us a five star review and a good
review don't be messing around
we got a couple trolls leaving bad
reviews so we gotta go balance those out
so go over
help us out on those directories give us
a five-star review or a good review what
whatever the the platform allows you to
do give us a good review over there on
that platform that you listen to your
podcast on and you can catch us there
too so this thing lives all kinds of
places youtube twitter twitch you just
type in tony michael's podcast you will
find it
or
or you can you can go to the midas touch
facebook page
and see it there live every day or
re-watch it on facebook
or you can listen to it on all
the directories just make sure you're
liking and subscribing wherever you're
listening
and if you come over to the the tubes of
you and you're on youtube you guys know
we have the super chat now
and i'm sure someone will give us a
super chat sometime today and you'll get
to see what the super chat's about so if
you haven't been over on youtube to see
what the super chat's about come on over
get in the chat here we go lisa's got a
super chat here she says happy 420 day
uh
thank you lisa for the super chat don't
spend all your money on the super chat
lisa you're gonna need it for the ganj
the ganja today
today's 4 20.
gotta spend gotta spend that gotta spend
that denero
on the wacky weed
happy 420 everyone happy wednesday i
think gabe sanchez my co-host and
executive producer is going to join us
at the bottom of the hour but today we
got a lot of tweety tweets and training
trends to go through i got a lot of
video i want to watch too with you guys
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] there's a lot of video
these people are crazy standing out in
front of disney
now you got kaylee mcinanny
talking some crazy ass [ __ ] she thinks
fetuses
are counted on the senses i'm not
[ __ ] you she thinks fetuses are
counted on the census
what a [ __ ] bonehead
so we have that trending uh julian
assange
it appears is going to be extradited to
the united states which is filling up
diapers down at mar-a-lago
now the diapers are full down at
mar-a-lago and they're getting fuller
at every passing moment
so we're gonna
we're gonna look at that we're gonna see
uh what julian assange what the word is
on julian assange uh here's ken
bonehead stoner of the week minus lisa
ah looks like ken
minus ken and midas lisa they're always
going back and forth with bonehead of
the chat but he's saying bonehead stoner
of the week
is midas lisa so apparently lisa is
toking today
congratulations lisa and maybe maybe i'm
not high i don't i don't smoke weed
never really have smoked wheat
um i never was into it i don't know it
just it just [ __ ] made me hungry
right like i get [ __ ] hungry i'd eat
a bag of doritos and then i i wouldn't
be high anymore
or like a package of hot dogs you know
you [ __ ] cook up a package of hot
dogs
you know something something you're
[ __ ] hungry right and you eat and
then you're not high anymore i don't
know i just
i i don't i always like to drink beer
i grew up in the catholic church so
everyone around me drank beer so we just
that's what we did
is he just drank beer amanda says wrong
strain tony i i don't i don't know
anything about marijuana either i really
don't i don't know anything about it
because i'm not i'm not a connoisseur or
anything
i just didn't and it's not
just is not
[Laughter]
maybe maybe one of these days maybe one
of these days um
i'll learn but i just it's
you know
i prefer i put my my drug of choice
is a couple beers
but you know i digress on the 420.
everyone else though you teach a zone
have fun on 420
have some fun
on 4 20. jamie says i'm high right now
like right now like right now
do you guys get high to listen to the
show like every day not just on 420
but every single day do you guys get
high to listen to the show i don't know
that that might be some good demographic
information that the suits would like to
know
[Laughter]
oh amanda says your liver hates you
my liver hates me because of the beer
yeah well i don't drink that often so i
used to drink more than i do now you
know when you're younger so
it happens it happens it happens
so let let's do this because we got a
lot of stuff to get to in the tweety
tweets and the trinity trends we got
this 1 billion stuff to work out it is
the anniversary i think it's a 23rd
anniversary of columbine
we also have fauci in the news because
the federal judge uh struck down the
masked mandate on airplanes and public
transportation travel
so we have that
uh and and i'm sure we're gonna have
some breaking news while we're on the
air
while we're on the air i'm sure there's
a republican somewhere that is gonna do
something [ __ ] dumb or fascist
for sure i mean they're banning math
abandoned math and florida and the
congresswomen
out in arizona don't know how to don't
know how to count
math is hard happy 420. let's start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we have reached the [ __ ] list roundup
part of the show and where we round up
all the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends as you know we go through the
news every single day right here to give
you your messaging give you your left
leaning that liberal socialist commie
libtard george soros funding messaging
you know
the good stuff
as opposed to the mainstream media who
always has to be fair and balanced and
give you the right wing slant on
everything get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] if you want to hear if you
want to hear straight at you in your
face raw
commentary on the news and on the issues
that are most affecting our country come
right here to the tony michaels podcast
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
twitch and now coming to you from the
midas touch facebook page
that's where we're at mama bird uh it's
given midas mighty
the midas mighty are joining us we also
have sparklers here too that come watch
the show
hal sparks fans come and watch the show
we have stuttering john fans that come
watch the show we got all kind we got a
diversity
of a group of people here
and we will welcome anyone else we even
have our own hate watchers folks
hate watchers chris in i know you're out
there chris in
give us give us something in the chat so
we we know you're there chris hen is our
local hate watcher we like chris in here
he's here every single day giving us the
hate watch so
we appreciate we appreciate all the
trolls and the hate watchers so watch
for him in the uh there's chris there's
chris
good morning chris good morning
everyone give us
and watch watch out for the trolls and
watch out for the hate watchers in the
youtube chat be nice
be nice they're here just to hate watch
i mean unless they're being [ __ ]
let me know if we get someone you know
throwing around racial slurs or being
[ __ ]
and we might consider
booting them but otherwise as long as
the trolls are behaving themselves and
the hate watchers are behaving
themselves they're here to hate watch
they are here
to hate watch and we must
we must respect
them watching and hating it's fine by me
it's fine by me maybe we'll teach them a
thing or two right chris right
okay let's get to the timeline of the
tweety tweets and trinity trends uh
let's see let's let's make this a little
bigger so you folks can see at home
this is
our great our great uh executive
producer came up with this uh slide
today for the have you guys noticed we
changed our thumbnails on youtube
we changed our thumbnails on youtube go
check it out gabe has been doing a great
job
at posting up some brand new thumbnails
every single morning that's why we've
been a little late getting the
announcement out is we're still trying
to figure out the uh the timing on these
things but he's coming up with these
great thumbnails every single morning
for the show
now are republicans high or just dumb
so that was the the and the title of the
show is math is hard happy 420.
so
go go
let gabe know and let us know in the
comments
of which is your favorite
thumbnail gabe's working hard on these
thumbnails so so do that for us
let's see what else we got here oh
i want to point something out we have
rhonda santas
on the thumbnail there
uh no line with brian tyler cohen
um he says just in ron desantis planned
to put punish disney for supporting
lgbtq rights
by repealing their special district
governing authority would raise taxes on
florida families in orlando area by 2
200 hours each
per the miami herald this is really
important so here we have ron desantis
doing a really [ __ ] stupid thing
by
by trying to go after disney okay
in florida and and if anyone doesn't
know walt disney world
the the compound of that is walt disney
world is [ __ ] humongous
it's the size of like five [ __ ]
counties it's not small
it's huge
and when they actually started the the
uh disney world project disney did
they went to the state of florida and
said hey we will have our own fire
departments we will have our own
security services we will have our own
public entities
our own public services
because it is so huge so you don't have
to provide
services we just want a special district
governing authority so that we can do so
disney
disney the company pays for all of that
right
not the property owners because when you
pay property tax in most states those
property tax goes to the schools they go
to the road department they go to the
fire department they go to the police
department they go all sorts of places
for all those public services taxes
is part of government spending
it doesn't it doesn't it's not wealth
distribution
it's called social services
they're community services their local
services
this is the things that you do like when
your [ __ ] house is on fire and you
call
ron
911
what he's doing
by punishing woke disney this is his
thing oh we're gonna punish woke disney
which is [ __ ] stupid
by repealing their special district
governing authority which sounds like
something special that disney gets right
but really who is the beneficiary
of that of that special district
governing authority is the people in
orlando because they don't have to fork
out their tax dollars for disney's roads
for disney's fire departments for disney
services
inside their huge ass compound
disney pays for that
right
this is really [ __ ] stupid and it's
[ __ ] backwards and it's no wonder
that a republican governor
is deciding to punish
punish floridians tax them they want to
tax floridians
because he has beef with mickey mouse
[Music]
ah these [ __ ] really don't know math
they really don't
and floridians should be absolutely
[ __ ] appalled at this not just the
people in orlando that the republican
governor is raising taxes on floridians
because he wants to have a political
battle with disney
because they oppose a bill that he wrote
because their employees said hey you
support this bill you better not support
this bill or will walk out and disney
made the right decision disney isn't
woke
disney just listened to their employees
you dumb [ __ ]
it's fantastic ron desantis is really
going this is the same stupid [ __ ] as
greg abbott stuffing up the border
with
to prevent groceries from getting to the
grocery stores in texas
it's the same stupid [ __ ] they can't end
they can't add i don't know if they're
high or they're just dumb
speaking of hi mj thank you
she says happy 420
busy as [ __ ]
love you all can't chat thank you very
much mj she gave
she gave four dollars
and 20 cents in celebration of 420.
thank you mj thank you so so much
now for being in the super chat
and i hope you can listen today even
though you can't chat
i hope you can listen
uh she also says
death satan is going down fucking's
times 1 million now 1 billion 1 billion
mj they can't count they can count to a
billion there's a billion
oh so they want to raise taxes on
families in orlando by 2 200 hours
each
each one of them that's how much it
costs for disney to have these services
inside their park and because the state
of florida grants them a special
district governing authority so that
they can legally have those services and
pay for those services
like this isn't like disney going rogue
or disney gets some kind of special
thing
this is just gives disney the authority
to govern over their land with some of
these special services
like fire departments yes the fire
departments inside disney disney owns
those fire departments
and that the reason why is because their
land mass is so big
it's [ __ ] humongous
and disney pays for it that's the
important part
but disney's disney's the one who's woke
do you remember a time do you remember
this is this is do you remember a time
in politics in this country there was a
guy named grover norco quest you
remember this guy this guy was all over
fox news he was all over the [ __ ]
media all the time
and he had a no tax pledge do you
remember this stupid [ __ ] where every
[ __ ] republican had to sign this
pledge never to raise taxes on anyone
ever ever in the history of ever ever or
they weren't a [ __ ] republican
you remember this [ __ ]
do you remember this
now we have ron desantis who is supposed
to be trump 2.0 down in florida oh floor
dark manga down in florida the let's go
brandon nazis love ron desantis and that
should tell you something right there
but they love him because he's gonna
raise taxes
think about this for a second think
about think about it think about it
think about it think about the messaging
think about how to win elections so that
we can set policy to make sure that
republicans are not raising
taxes on the middle class because
they want to raise taxes on the middle
class by 4 500
in a federal tax scheme
to make sure they tax the middle class
because they don't think the middle
class are paying enough they're not
paying their fair share they're not
broke enough yet
that's the republican way here
same [ __ ] same [ __ ] that
used to
continue on about the national debt and
how [ __ ] taxes are burning people and
we can't oh too many taxes you remember
the tea party
when barack obama the black dude was
president they had the tea party which
is which is a predecessor
which is a predecessor tamaga
taxed enough already is what tea party
stood for that's what they said it stood
for taxed enough already
here ron desantis is
we're not even 15 years later
past the tea party
and all the all the [ __ ] tea party
here's their [ __ ] manga
and dark manga now you know they're they
moved to the dark side
we have dark maga now down in florida
and ron desantis
raising taxes because he hates mickey
mouse
he hates mickey mouse
we have governor greg abbott another
dark manga
in texas
making sure that grocery store shelves
are empty on purpose
because trucks are coming across the
border
and he wants to check their [ __ ] tire
pressure
and he got on fox news and said i don't
give a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
if there's empty grocery store shelves
or not i don't care trump told me that i
have to make sure that there's a crisis
at the border and by god i'm gonna
manufacture one that's what he said
that's what he said
i'll show you the [ __ ] tape here in a
little bit
greg abbott went on fox news and said i
don't care
what happens
i'm going to manufacture a crisis at the
border because trump told me to
and the reason why is because we need we
need to make americans afraid of brown
people that's what we need to do we need
to make people afraid of gay people
that's what we need to do
we need to make sure that we pass laws
that are discriminatory against gay
people that take women's liberty away
and sexualize children's gender and we
marry them that's what we want and by
the way on top of that while we're at it
let's tax the [ __ ] out of them and let's
make sure there's no groceries on your
shelves that's the republican policy
folks
that's their policy what is it then you
tell me you tell me what that what
they're [ __ ] running on you tell me
what they're legislating if they're not
legislating that kind of [ __ ]
no parent in this [ __ ] country
is worried about a kindergartner
learning about sex unless you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and the reason why is
because they don't teach sex in k-3
it's the pedo cons it's the republican
kid dealers that are that are [ __ ]
sexualizing gender and that's why we're
here with this ron desantis woke disney
story
is because they want to sexualize kids
gender
and they want to sexualize gender in in
general
in general they want to sexualize gender
that's what the whole don't say gay bill
is about is to make sure that if johnny
has two two two dads that he can't say
he has two dads you can't say that
johnny you can't say that your dads are
gay
oh sally has two mommies sally you can't
say you have two mommies because that
means you have to say gay
and wet just oh that would just hurt our
delicate sensibilities
if we if we come to the realization that
little sally here who is a who is a
smart
normal
child
in kindergarten has two mommies it would
really upset us
if if a functioning child could have two
mommies because it goes against our
[ __ ] narrative
all in an effort all in an effort
to tax floridians
twenty two hundred dollars each
because
mickey mouse is the enemy
oh boy
[Applause]
we have someone joining us good morning
gabe how are you
oh good morning yeah 4
so are you uh are you uh baked raked or
what what's going on oh dude i'm baked
raked and
chicken shaked i don't know what i don't
know are you trying to rhyme are you
yeah well i was you know uh yeah no i'm
not i'm uh
i'm not uh
not baked right now you're not a 420
connoisseur you're not a marijuana
i'm not a connoisseur okay well i i
partake though it is funny because i did
you live in california so well yeah and
i also i also started a cannabis company
uh
with a few friends back in 2015. oh okay
so you see you're you're entrenched in
the um in the industry yeah yeah i used
to work like in that industry
um
not just as in like like you know you
weren't just testing the product you
were you were right right i mean
obviously there was quality control and
you had to make sure the product oh yeah
you know right yeah no i was uh i wasn't
we we created a
a cannabis
uh subscription service um
anyone can google it it was called
potbox
what is it called it's called pot box
p-o-t-b-o-x hot pot pot box
yeah so there's articles anyone ever say
to you hey nice box nice box uh they did
because if you look at the photos they
were very well photographed oh okay nice
but nice box nice box nice box i don't
know so so so
do you you don't partake as much anymore
though they are are you going to
celebrate on 420 by
i'll celebrate i'll do
i'll probably i've got some honey you
know some like cbd i guess oh okay thc
honey so okay i'll probably you know put
some in my tea
you know
maybe put some on my toast you know i
don't think this is what i don't think
this is what like snoop dogg and willie
nelson think of like when they think
420. you don't like a guy a guy eating
ate and honey on uh um thc honey on
toast you think that's weird but also
keep in mind that that those two have
like the tolerance level
of it just
someone from outer space it's so crazy
high and extreme
um
but
who knows man you know i don't know
maybe he's like mixing it with t and
then he's having a little j and then
we'll come on later he like gets the
bong and then boom pulls out another j
you know who knows you know
you know the saddest part about us
sitting here joking about this the fact
that um the 420 and there's states that
have this legal of course you know
they're trying to pass through congress
and and and republicans were absolutely
[ __ ] hell-bent on making sure that
marijuana stayed illegal in this country
like no it's a gateway drug
like a gateway to i mean like gateway to
what to other marijuana when you go to
the the dispensary i mean literally the
only reason why it's quote-unquote a
gateway is because you had to go to a
drug dealer who not just dealt marijuana
but they you know they had pills they
had heroin you know
they had a whole smorgasbord of drugs
they're a drug dealer but now now that
you can go get you know nice fresh you
know
marijuana
at a dispensary you know where it is you
know where it's been you know it's came
from
it's not it's a
marijuana at a dispensary is a gateway
to other marijuana products like that's
right well also the assumption that it's
like
you know you've got people like uh nancy
reagan uh who is the bj queen from what
i've read
what the what the what the bj queen the
bj queen yeah i guess nancy reagan was
notorious for blow jobs
well not
news breaking news i did not know this
breaking news yeah where where did you
hear this is this one like it was in a
book it was oh well you know if you
write it it also was it was on it was
like trending for like three days and
people were like oh my god and they were
like reassessing photos that were taken
of nancy reagan like there was one
photo of her taken with um mr t
yeah man uh
because mr t is really happy after he
took a picture she was sitting in his
lap and people were like oh oh it was
just like a lot of jokes are made about
i see i see yeah december 13th it said
vice did a thing on like why are people
tweeting this was last year the throat
goat the throat goat oh well so she's
not the bj queen she's the throat goat
oh uh oh are you gonna tell me
okay allegedly allegedly i'm not i
didn't know this
foreign allegedly gave the greatest
[ __ ] in hollywood back in her acting
days and she gave a lot of them
allegedly well that now ever for
everyone to know nancy nancy was um a
female actor because that that's how her
and ronald reagan met because ronald
reagan actually had you know wife before
nancy you know this that nancy was his
second wife right right
oh
mj's another 420 from nj she says start
the celebration now now mj we're talking
we're not
we kind of got off the subject of 420
and we'll go back in a second now gabe's
talking about uh bj's so i don't know
i'm just saying i'm just saying the
person who was fundamental right in the
war on drugs yeah was one who did other
things outside and i you know what i
wouldn't be surprised if she was also
toking up herself
you know well i mean this this is this
is typical republican fashion where you
know you someone or something you know
they've been doing this the last two
years talking about how oh
gender and sexualization and genetic and
they're absolutely obsessed with it like
no one else is worried about people's
genitalian bathrooms no one's worried
about rather johnny the kindergartner
has two dads or two no one's really
worried about that no one sexualizes
that but republicans republicans
sexualize gender they sexualize who you
love who you marry they sexualize all
that stuff because they they can't you
know they can't get their minds out of
anything so i would not be surprised if
nancy reagan wanted to ban drugs and
blow jobs because she just couldn't she
just couldn't get her focus off anything
else you know being the throat goat i
mean let's just
remember
when you point a finger at someone else
there are three
pointing right back at you
and that is a republican party they are
just
guilty
is that a dad joke did you did you did
you get told no isn't that a quote from
a song well i'd hate you i feel like
i've heard it from a song before but
i've heard that before where it's like
the point is like if you're pointing a
finger at someone else guaranteed that
you're actually talking about yourself
donald trump is a very key
uh oh absolutely what you know you know
what people are saying i heard right now
yeah you said you do right well you know
that that's that that's a decent point
because uh there's a i think it's in the
bible i i don't know i don't know yeah
that's protest too much i think it's the
uh all right um
i don't know i think it might be about
casting the first oh okay yeah right
right right something like that
something like that um but anyways
but anyways the i don't read the bible a
lot do you do you read the bible
i haven't read the bible since i was in
high school actually i read the bible
but i wrote it back in high school right
i i have a well we're both catholics so
that we were we were put in a room and
forced to read it and to each other like
really weirdly that is actually how tony
and i know each other yeah we were
forced to read the bible together
together yeah it was early early zoom
calls except it was over the phone right
right right
bible readings yeah it was it was bible
bible phone party right right and well i
got a clip i want to show you about the
bible here later on but i want to finish
our part 420 talk here yeah yeah because
it is happy 420.
you you made the i i pointed that to
everyone out that that you've been
making the new thumbnails and today's
was great today's was great it was it
was basically the title of the show is
math is hard happy for 20. right but you
made the thumbnail and it says are
republicans higher they just dumb
because we have
we have not only ron desantis is trying
to ban math i mean literally trying to
ban math in florida we have a
congresswoman from arizona who
apparently thinks one-third of the
world's population has come across the
border and not only that not only has
one that a billion people come across
the border but but homeland security by
the bible administration has apprehended
every single one of them yeah it's like
what happened was they
they went across the border got
apprehended then they were like all
right go back and come back again
and it's like a bouncer at the at the
door who's like clicking people in he's
like okay 32 33
he's like all right we got you so is
there like a long line of a billion
people like yeah they just have to keep
going like with the red rope around
yeah yeah exactly yeah they're like oh
one by one you try to come in and
they're like oh nope sorry i can't come
in but you gotta go to the back of the
line so then you just double count they
don't even know who the people are oh
okay so it's not really a billion
they're just double counting somebody
exactly or you know quadruple right
whatever i don't some some at crazy x
factor
but here's the thing is she reads she
quotes she she quotes an article right
from the new york times that says a
million let's show it here let's show it
yeah here's here's the because she has
deleted this tweet right all right and
here's the thing if you've ever learned
anything about twitter uh you always got
to get that screenshot because right
well and it and and to be to be quite
honest about the truth here gabe it
wasn't new york times it was wall street
journal here oh wall street journal
sorry sorry fake news wall street fake
fake news so the the the wall street
journal and of course we can't it even
says one million right
right one million in six months now
here's here's the here's the thing about
this this uh this quote here right
mexican border arrest top 1 million in
six months now this is the same stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ] when they're talking about
when they're talking about yeah they're
like oh my god
biden sees a gazillion pounds of vietnam
coming across the border like yeah that
that
is the deep dude yeah like you
apprehended
and it it amazes me that they can't
figure this out and it's the same way
with this
so what they're saying is
one million arrests made
um in six months which which means that
when people are coming across the board
they're actually apprehending them now
a arrest is kind of a rough word because
i actually don't believe there are a
quote-unquote arresting election i mean
it may be official arrest but they're
they might be like detained and they're
transported but they're not getting
arrested right right and sent to jail
right these are human beings and they
should be treated like human beings and
i hope that uh
now that the bite administration has had
its hands on dhs for some time that
they're being more humane i believe that
there's probably cause to uh make sure
that the bite administration and hold
them accountable that they are being
humane and being more humane towards
these people because these are human
[ __ ] beings right and they're coming
here for a reason they're not just
coming here with druids and crap you
know that's all [ __ ] right they're
coming here for a reason um and most of
the time the reason is is that they are
looking for american opportunity like
that's that's what they're looking for
and also they're looking for a job like
that you know we got five million more
positions in this country than we have
people unemployed so they're looking for
a job so to help the economy and that's
the reason why we have such a shitty
shitty unemployment in our and some of
those help wanted signs are [ __ ] up is
because the trump administration for so
many years
was
such uh bigots towards migrants not just
not just people from mexico but people
from all all around the world coming in
legally not just illegally but legally
as well so that's important but this
bonehead says here
uh congressman dev debbie lasko so now
she's deleted this tweet yeah you can't
go uh troll this tweet but you
definitely even here's the thing some of
these tweets are always like oh there's
no way that person said that and i will
usually like link it below and then this
morning i want to go check and it was
deleted it's deleted so
like sometimes they double down and
they're like whatever
because
you put this tweet out last night
because it was yesterday when right
right so like one what time did i put
that out if you look at the timestamp
well
let me oh you're in the photo i'm in the
photo here let's go back so here's
here's from gabe said from the party
that brought you math books teach crt i
give you one billion migrants uh you
posted it at 12 14 my time so that's
central so 10 so 10 14 p.m i think she
had done it two hours prior so 8 14 p.m
my time so this had been a while but she
says border patrol agents have
apprehended more than
1 billion she tried to she wanted to get
as many
1 billion migrants um
she wanted to get the uh as many zeros
as she could on here i think right
you know and really honestly she should
have just typed gazillions yeah like i
mean i think that's what she should have
done she would have been much better
she'd have been in much better shape
here for it not to go viral um she types
in one billion migrants at our southern
border in just six months president
biden's open border policies are fueling
this crisis they're not open borders
yeah if they're if they're apprehending
a billion migrants
sounds like a pretty close border right
well you know
i mean some would say yeah again again i
think i think uh there is cause to make
sure that the biden administration the
dhs are still being humane to these
migrants exactly what i said was
when biden arrest one billion migrants
at the border who needs a stupid [ __ ]
wall pew pew pew pew pew pew pew pew pew
pew i mean because that isn't that what
you would think
yeah it really is trump supporters i
mean think about think about the
headline if this was when trump
is arrested yeah one minute oh they
would be they would be oh my god look at
this this is this is crazy good we're
doing such a great job president trump
is shutting down the border and doing
what you're supposed to do and thought
it out on the snap yeah of course i mean
it was the other way around they would
uh they'd push it to be that trump was
this you know the
second coming of christ
right well one of the best which is
funny because that's not how christ
would treat people but you know it is
right
that's just you mean you mean christ
would be kind to migrants are you it's
crazy are you that's a guy who looks
right
a migrant a migrant
someone who comes from another country
who is darker in skin not white not the
republican jesus like they say
would be kind especially to people who
didn't look like himself even if he was
a white republican jesus the whole thing
is be kind to others like you want to
treat others as you want to be treated
yourself so it's like
to dismiss and dehumanize and throw
people to the side like that doesn't
sound very christ-like that's not very
christian-like are they really that
christian i think i think it's they hide
behind their religious dogma oh yeah
exactly hide their bigotry because they
can say [ __ ] one day and then they can
turn around on sunday and say oh
you know praise be i you know forgive me
god i go to confession and then and then
the pastor priest whoever says okay now
in order for that confession and this
whole uh moment to be wiped clean you
have to give us some money and they go
oh yes of course of course of course
because it goes to god you know and then
and then that priest or that you know
mega church evangelist says well in
order for me to get those messages to
god you have to buy me a new g5
[Laughter]
well i mean there is there is there is
given pull gabe right crying out loud
when you're when you when you're when
you're doing oopsies right
speaking of holy holy [ __ ] eric swalwell
says
one-eighth of the planet's population
went to the southern border this year
question mark and we apprehended all of
them question mark debbie you want to
delete this tweet
uh uh
do you want to delete this tweet are you
good question mark and then look look
the tweet has been deleted eric swalwell
is one of the best trolls that we have
he's great he's he's great he's he's
fantastic uh you know what maybe maybe
the billion people were just going to
the border so they could find their way
to cancun right they were like hey what
is the route that ted cruz took right
maybe they were trying maybe they were
trying right right spring break is
happening isn't it or did it happen it's
like around this time
around board 20 yeah well you know
go to 420 hang out with the cartel do
the whole thing right right right well
you know it could happen that way sir
eric swalwell i i want to show you a
video though so kind of speaking of holy
[ __ ] and the bible we've been really on
this religious stuff this morning
um i'm going to show you a video from
it's morning morning thoughts and
prayers you know yeah well
morning morning thoughts and prayers so
there there's a um
there's a good liars video out
now for all you guys know the good liars
are fantastic and they go to a lot of
trump rallies and some of these some of
these dark manga gatherings you know i
don't know if they're like seances or
what they are but they go and they they
ask these people questions and here is
uh this guy's name is ralph rambett
rambant sounds made up sounds totally
made up
well he may be but he's he says he's
running
for the governor from who oh for the
governor well i mean he's running for
governor to run away from his pedophilia
probably got it i mean he is republican
and he is very religious so i'm sure he
would love to marry you know teenage
girls this is the thing these
republicans do but listen to what he
says about schools the bible and banning
books listen listen to this exchange
here it's fantastic my name is ralph
rebent and i'm running for the governor
of michigan i'm a pastor but i'm running
on bringing god back into culture
because i'm convinced that if we don't
get god right in this next election
nothing will matter he thinks that if
they don't get god right i don't know
what that means like
i like what they that
is literally on our currency i know well
it's like it's on it's on all the police
cars now even yeah and it's everywhere
it's [ __ ] everywhere it's [ __ ]
everywhere i don't understand this and
and technically
you can pray in the school there's
nothing keeping you yeah yeah i mean
yeah yeah well yeah yeah
i mean that that's the thing is you can
pray in a school when i when i was in
school they had prayer before school
they would actually go out by the
flagpole
and they would and they would pray at
the flagpole it's called meet you at the
flag
prayer isn't banned from school that's
all a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] unless
you're talking about a bunch of white
people banning muslim prayer from school
they'll probably do that but let's
listen let's listen to what this guy
says about the bible and banning books
this is super important bringing god
back to michigan um what would that look
like would there be religion taught in
schools
uh there would be uh as our founders
said the bible should be the basic
textbook and scripture i mean in schools
are there the basic the bible would be
the basic
what in school when did our founders say
that type of [ __ ] these people make up
so much [ __ ] [ __ ] this is the whole
trump thing that you're a lot of people
are saying that the founders a lot of
people are saying people people said
they really want to have more religious
uh scripture in in their uh math study
and it's like whoever said that well you
know there is crt in math too so that is
right but let's let's listen to what um
so what he says about banning books
because this is this is this is [ __ ]
just great watch this for books that you
don't want to see in schools
uh i would remove the pornography but we
need to ban we need to ban books that
have pornographic
imagery in them right who who had porn
at their i want to know what he's told
this is he talking about sex ed
what is he talking about i have no idea
i i did not have i mean we had porn at
school but we had to sneak it in they
weren't providing in his curriculum i
don't know what school you went to tony
i didn't have a part of my i wasn't
trying to oh come on
why would i bring porn why would i bring
porn into a place that would get me
busted with porn
that's the whole point right no the
rules the rules are made to be broken
we would have to sneak porn into school
i did not know there were schools out
there that provided that provided this
type of pornography i did not know that
that's because they don't exist the same
way kindergarteners don't learn sex ed
i feel like maybe he's getting confused
with sex ed which is not taught until
you're uh 13. what you're watching here
at 7th or 8th grade when you're going
through puberty and you're learning
about the body even i had that at my
catholic grade school however it was a
little bit tainted
by uh
the catholic side of it which was like
you know easy on the language there
there you see on the easy on the
language there priest gabe okay look
look
all right so the point is
i mean i used it intentionally
the point is
um
even at my catholic school we learned
about sex ed but that wasn't until we
were like 13 or 14 and even then our
stuff was like totally kind of okay fine
sugar coated
okay
with the uh religious side of it which
was like oh you can't masturbate because
that's a sin and you're killing humans
and
all this stuff what's porn four if not
for masturbation i don't know we could
go ask josh hawley let's let's see let's
see let's see what kind of pornography
though that this pastor who's running
for governor let's see what kind of
pornography he actually wants in school
let's listen
yes yes because because we somebody was
telling us about a book that had like
two daughters getting their dad drunk
and having sex with them i know you're
going that way i know you're doing that
yeah that's a good point you're saying
so he knows he's going there but
basically if you're not he's like i know
that story he's starting to cue up the
bible here right which is part of
genesis um
the book of genesis
and he's queuing this up and the guy
knows where he's going and the reason
why the guy knows where he's going is
because he's a pastor he has probably
read the bible and he's read all the bio
[ __ ] that's in the bible like he's read
it so but but listen to his argument
here this is republican 101 republican
101 because it's the bible it's not bad
no matter how pornographic or how
genocidal or how murderous right it
actually is can you ban the bible in
school
uh no i'm not saying ban the bible in
school i i get where you're going with
your questions right because it's
because it's a you're saying anything
that has a pornographic image should be
banned and that there are some images in
the bible about you know sex and incest
and things like that so
sounds like you're saying we should ban
the bible
uh
what i am saying is that the
judeo-christian principles on which our
country is founded need to be brought
back into culture and i i can't say it
any more clearly than that when did we
lose our judeo-christian
culture are you [ __ ] kidding me
even two weeks before halloween this
[ __ ] country is stuff full of
christmas trees for crying out loud and
it's thrown in our face santa claus
christmas cheese i mean you got the
easter bunny you know showing up yeah
at the beginning of new year you know
it's like even before you see
valentine's stuff there's a bunch of
pink [ __ ] in the hallway of course there
is why wouldn't there be cupid cupid and
and the easter bunny are lovers you know
that's what's wrong with our country is
is they're they're gay what's this right
you got the sweet baby cherub and a
bunny what the hell is that about east
oh my god these [ __ ] christians let's
let's finish up this guy's shitty
argument um that means spanning the
bible so be it
the bible would not be banned from
culture
or from the schools understand the
schools to protect the kids
[Laughter]
oh my god perfect kid just to protect it
it is solid i mean the
the you know uh save our children
protect the kids like whenever it's
brought up back on those group where
it's like hey listen so uh
looks like another person from the
republic republican party was uh was
caught for pedophilia or child porn or
whatever it is
and they're like
uh
put up the blinders and you're like we
got to protect the kids right and
they're like well
not not from them they're good white
people right right right they're not
they're not they're good christian judeo
cards it's like listen there could have
been a totally good reason for why there
were hard drives like terabytes worth of
data with child pornography on that
senator's computer right it was doing
research that's what he was right right
probably he was probably downloading
hunter biden's laptop right exactly it's
for the same reasons that you know when
i made that video about josh hawley i
guarantee there's a bunch of porn all
some weird [ __ ] on his computer and for
him he's like i'm doing research on it
you know he's completely obsessed with
porn republicans are completely obsessed
with other people's gender other
people's sexuality because they can't
figure out their own and i said this the
other day i said this the other day the
reason why tucker carlson did his whole
man men aren't manly anymore documentary
is because they're terrified absolutely
terrified of sexuality and they're
terrified
white
cisgendered dudes are terrified of their
insecurities of their homosexual
tendencies that's what it is they're
absolutely
terrified of it yeah so much so a lot of
a lot of projects yep a lot of
projection just projecting in the
universe and they can't quit they just
can't they can't
oh man well thanks for joining us gabe i
think you got to jump here right you got
to jump yeah all right well everyone
stick around we'll be right back more
shitless roundup right after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc we was 50
strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the
live loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
remember every single weekday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
right here on youtube twitter twitch
now coming to you from the midas touch
facebook page we're on the books of face
everybody
let's get back to the shitless roundup i
got a couple clips some more video i
want to react to some more video i want
to show you
oh
blonde blonde bombshell barbie
kaylee mcinney oh jesus
fascist barbie kaylee mcenany
thinks
that fetuses
are counted in the senses i'm not
[ __ ] you i'm i'm not kidding and
this isn't really surprising they can't
do [ __ ] math they're banning math
because they can't do it they don't know
how many people are coming across the
border they can't read an article
kaylee mcinanny thinks the census counts
fetuses they just can't count they can't
do math they're [ __ ] dumb
let's listen to what kaylee mcinerney
has to say
on fox news let me make this a little
bigger so you can see this bonehead i
think the press secretary should cry
about the 62 million children that do
not exist that have been aborted because
of roe v wade a heinous heinous decision
in this country that has exterminated
about one-fifth of the united states
population so
she's saying
that abortion has exterminated listen to
her words here now this is something i
keep telling people do not look away do
not look away
this [ __ ] idiot right here you want
to know about messaging you want to know
about it you want to know what what
their message is going to be do you want
to know what their message is going to
be to women out there that they're
taking their women liberty away they're
going to tell you that the reason why
they're getting rid of abortion is
because democrats and the left is
exterminating children that's their plan
that's their plan she's telling you
right here
what their message is gonna be
their plan is not gonna be oh well we
think abortion wrong and they're not
gonna debate when when life starts when
life they're not gonna do that that's
not the argument that they're gonna make
in this election and i'm talking about
the 2022 midterm
kaylee mcinnany here is giving away
their message
she's telling you what her their
argument is going to be
and they're all going to adopt it
every last one of them are going to say
this
mark my words listen again they're going
to say this
decision in this country that has
exterminated about one-fifth of the
united states population so
roe v wade the worst decision in our
country that has exterminated one-fifth
of our population
that is going to be their message of why
they're stripping liberty away from
women
it's really [ __ ] dumb
to think that an eptopic pregnancy is
counted on the senses
it's really [ __ ] dumb
it's really dumb that a woman who has to
have a procedure because her fetus is
not viable and her life is in danger
that that fetus is counted on the
population
they're dehumanizing people and children
at the border but they're humanizing a
non-viable fetus
because they're going after every
[ __ ] every procedure that is
considered an abortion folks
and and they're saying it ron desantis
said it the other day in front of a
[ __ ] microphone he said they want to
abort babies up until
nine months which is [ __ ] not true
that is such a bunch of [ __ ] no
democrat anywhere is passing in
legislation that lets that lets someone
who has a a [ __ ]
abort that baby up to nine months
that evidence doesn't exist because it's
not [ __ ] true
but you do have evidence
you do have evidence of oklahoma the
state of florida the state of missouri
the state of texas
the state of tennessee
confed cheeto confederacy state after
cheeto confederacy state passing laws to
take away people who have uteruses
liberty away from their bodies and away
from them about their bodies
and this is their message folks
that's why i show this stuff i don't
show this stuff just to [ __ ] get all
pissed off i'm telling you what their
message is gonna be
i'm telling you what they're gonna run
on
and the only way to combat and to win an
election is to know what your opponent's
message is gonna be and here's the great
part about republicans that they're
really [ __ ] good at and that we suck
at is they're all on the same [ __ ]
team no matter how [ __ ] vile it is
they don't give a [ __ ] how vile the
rhetoric they don't care how vile the
candidate jesus christ there is a god
damn rapist
a blackmailing rapist who stole money
from a veteran's charity is gonna be
who is who who beats his kids and beats
his wife apparently in affidavits
who is going to be the united states
senator on the republican ticket the
candidate for the united states senate
in missouri eric greitens the disgraced
governor who duct taped a woman to a
treadmill got her naked took pictures
and used those pictures as blackmail to
do sexual acts on her
he also stole money from a veterans
charity and oh by the way there are
reports from affidavits in court that
his ex-wife sheena says that he was
violent with her and her children
that
is going to be their nominee
and eric greitens is going to be running
around the state of missouri saying just
what kaylee mcany said he's going to say
roe v wade is the worst decision in our
country because it is exterminated
exterminated one-fifth of the united
states population that's what he's going
to say and that's why he's gonna say
that he's willing to take away your
[ __ ] liberty
because he loves the children or some
stupid [ __ ]
he loves the children i mean the
children that aren't born yet the
children that aren't even viable yet but
the children at the border [ __ ] those
children
[ __ ] those children they're brown
children we don't want those children
send those children back to where they
came from [ __ ] those children
that's what we have to do that's that's
the hill they're gonna die on
that's the [ __ ] hill they're gonna
die on they're gonna die on that hill
they're gonna die on the hill
of that roe v wade is the most
egregious decision in this country
because it has exterminated
listen
you don't think this is projection
this is this is the same [ __ ]
projection
when they're when they're sexualizing
your kid's gender this is the same
[ __ ] projection when they're using
anti-gay
marriage
cause to pass a marriage bill so they
can marry your marry your children in
missouri tennessee and others
the same kid diddle and [ __ ]
that they're doing when they when they
sexualize your kid's gender and they
want to marry him same kid diddle and
[ __ ]
don't believe me
think about the projection here
think about think about who they love
what children they love to exterminate
they're passing bills they're passing
bills
all over this country republicans are
trying to pass bills to ostracize lgbtq
kids from their communities
they locked kids up at the border for
four [ __ ] years in cages
you don't think
you don't think that this is that this
is projection
from kaylee mcinning in the republican
party
i mean kaylee mcaney isn't stupid enough
to think that fetuses
are counted on the on the united states
census
she's not that [ __ ] dumb
i mean she appears to be that [ __ ]
dumb every once in a while
but she's not that [ __ ] dumb
this is their message this is their
projection and they're going to continue
it and this is what this is how they're
going to justify taking away women's
liberty in states
this is how they're going to justify
taking away your consent for your
children
that's what they're doing with these
with these trans athlete bills
is to eat away at parents consent
and if they do it to these this group of
man if they can pass a bill to take away
parents consent for a handful of kids in
each state
and the legislators like yup and the
governor's like yup do it [ __ ] it and
all the school board like yep let's vote
it in let's discriminate against nobody
but a handful of
of of students and make sure we take the
consent away from those parents you
don't think they're gonna come after
your children's con the consent that you
have over your
children if they can take the consent of
four kids in utah
that [ __ ] governor in utah vetoed
that trans athlete bill because he said
it only affects four
four children in his state and he's a
republican and he was not willing
to pass a law
that affects only four children
he was not willing and the legislator
overturned it just like that
just like that they overturned it
no one said a [ __ ] thing i mean i did
on my show but no one said a [ __ ]
thing
they overturned the consent of those
four children's parents in the state of
utah
when the governor vetoed it
and they're coming after your consent
for your children that's what they're
doing that's what the [ __ ] that's
what the the stupid marriage law the
alternative marriage laws that they're
trying to pass that looks like it's
anti-gay because that's that's how they
get their base all excited is to make
them that's what the trans bill is about
it's all
anti-lgbtq it's all the anti others
that get them all riled up about it
but in reality
the ant the anti-trans athlete bills
that they're passing is a way for them
to take consent away from parents
just the same way that the alternative
anti-gay marriage bill in tennessee was
guys to marry children
to not have an age limit
just like the bill
in florida who they said well we don't
want to teach sex ed to kindergarteners
they're not they
weren't is to make sure that those
parents aren't recognized in their state
oh you want to get married as gay
parents and have children in our schools
well you can do that but you can't be
recognized as mom and mom and dad and
dad can't do that we will not recognize
you as lgbtq we will not recognize you
in our schools you cannot say that
little sally has gay parents you can't
do it
all the while taking consent away from
your children
they took away consent of children in
florida they didn't give freedom
they took it
and that's what these dumb [ __ ]
don't understand and they're not going
to understand it to stand around and try
to talk to a bunch of [ __ ] trump
supporters to get them to understand
what freedom rights and liberty are it's
a waste of your [ __ ] time waste your
time you might as well not even you
might as well not even do it
they're delusional they're way down the
[ __ ] rabbit hole they're going to
listen to kaylee mcinning here and go
yeah they're exterminating the fifth of
our population
the people that we can make sure that we
get to our messaging to
is the generic ballot people who are not
paying attention to politics like you
great folks do everyone on here pays
attention to politics every single day
you guys are well educated well versed
in what's going on in the world and in
our country as it pertains to politics
most people could tell you more about a
reality show that's on thursday nights
then they could tell you about the
united states government
you guys are not there you're there with
the government not with the reality show
and it's those people who have to be
given our message that hey
hey
look over here just because you voted
trump out
doesn't mean that they're not trying to
do trumpism things they're trying to
take your liberty away hello
that's what we have to do we have to get
our messaging right
so these folks know that the republican
kid diddlers are trying to take your
consent away from your children all the
while sexualizing their gender and
wanting to marry them
and while while they want to commit
genocide against other children because
kaylee mcaney is not outraged about
vladimir putin murdering innocent
children in ukraine
under the guise of making sure that
democracy does not stand she has no
outrage about that
if you notice
about those children being killed
i mean vladimir putin her hero is
killing those children so it must not be
extermination they must have deserved it
you don't think they're gonna turn
that attitude towards your children
kaylee mcaney is completely obsessed
completely obsessed
with unviable fetuses being considered
for the census
but she could not give two [ __ ] shits
not two [ __ ] shits
about the children being murdered in
ukraine by the murderous dictator
vladimir putin who she loves
who she hails as her great leaders
pimp
don't get it twisted
they'll turn that attitude to towards
you
oh well i see here on social media
that you're one of them liberal libtards
and you have children hmm
well our dictator and cheeto dust
mobster and mango mussolini jesus
says that you're bad
hmm
maybe we should put you in a camp
we'll call it a re-education camp
doubt me go ahead
don't participate in your democracy
because it's not just going and voting
that's not what it's about
i said this last week all week last week
when we found out that ron desantis and
the republicans are trying to ban math
just ask someone at your grocery store
ask someone at your church
ask someone at your work
just ask them the question did you hear
that florida's trying to ban math
i bet they're like what what the hell
are you talking about what do you
thought they won't even know
you don't have to get down in the weeds
when you ask the question did you hear
that governor ron desantis wants to ban
54 math books from the curriculum of
florida's arithmetic you don't have to
get down in the weeds
you do not have to get down in the weeds
stop that [ __ ]
liberals do that they want to throw a
goddamn of psychopedia at you just to
make a [ __ ] point
ron desantis is banning math in florida
did you hear that did you hear that did
you hear that florida's trying to ban
math
i guarantee you
i guarantee you
they're going to say i know i didn't
hear that i i didn't hear that
i don't know hey
i did i did see that jan that jan on the
reality show got
she got voted off last night boy that
was [ __ ] awesome
i seen that the cardinals kicked ass
yesterday
yeah sure that's all cool that's fine
but are you paying attention to what
they're actually going to do to our
country because you're not going to have
the reality shows and the sports that
you like
that community center that you have that
church you have that school where you
you go to your pta
nope not gonna have that under the
fascist state
you think you're gonna have all that no
that's not their goal their goal is to
tear it all down all of it the whole
thing
they want to destroy public education
that's what they're trying to do
is to absolutely tear it down and
destroy it
and the reason why is because they know
that's the only way they can make it as
fascist as they want
make all the teachers all the principals
all those liberal
propagandists inside our public
education system
make them quit
make them not make make education not
bearable for them anymore and then they
can hire a bunch of fascists
to run their education system
i'd go ahead doubt me i i don't give a
[ __ ]
but this is their messaging listen to it
one more time listen made a heinous
heinous decision in this country that
has exterminated about one-fifth of the
united states population so if you want
to cry don't cry about forcing sexuality
on kindergartners that is sick cry about
the 62 million children who can't even
go to kindergarten
i told you it's projection
no one's teaching sex to children you
people are obsessed with children's
gender you're sexualizing children's
gender you're sexualizing gender in
in general actually
because you're [ __ ] weirdos
you're [ __ ] weirdos
oh well what are you gonna do i can only
yell and scream into the microphone
you do with it what you want
oh here uh uh wu-tang for children uh
jim jordan tweeted fouchy lost freedom
one
oh my god
i think he's retweeting this about the
[ __ ] mask mandate
saying that faunchi lost
which it really wasn't falchi's policy
necessarily it was the biden
administration's policy
um you know that falchi was part of the
trump administration too right jim
jordan
jim i don't report sex crimes jordan
we dang for children says one million
dead americans couldn't be reached for
comment
a million people have died in this
country of coronavirus
and a large number of those people have
died in this country because of
republicans policy or lack thereof when
it comes to covid
jim jordan is a [ __ ] bonehead
maybe he'll end up on bonehead of the
week speaking of bonehead of the week
don't forget to go follow us
on twitter at tony michael's pod we will
be posting the bonehead of the week poll
tomorrow boy do we have a shitload
[ __ ] load of boneheads to pick from this
week
go over there and
uh
follow us and you'll be able to vote so
here's what we do we put up
the bonehead of the week poll
every single week
with three
boneheads
and you guys get the vote who is the
bonehead of the week we're practicing
democracy and it's one of the only
chances that you'll actually vote for
one of these idiots
otherwise you wouldn't vote for him
otherwise you know like in a real
election
but you get to vote for who the bonehead
of the week is and then on friday in the
second hour of the show
the second hour on friday me and gabe go
through your vote we go through what you
voted on who is the bone end of the week
and we had some salty mix in there you
know with the alpha cuck of the week and
the dishonorable mention so don't forget
to follow at tony michael's pod
the twitter page and go vote for
bonehead of the week every single week
every single week
okay
um mayo says
let's make this bigger so you can see
mayo says who else thinks wearing a mask
on a plane during a pandemic or not
wearing excuse me who else thinks not
wearing a mask on a plane a plane during
a pandemic is really [ __ ] stupid
it is really [ __ ] dumb even during
flu season
it would be probably smart to wear a
[ __ ] mask on an airplane
if you're during flu season people are
spreading around the flu if you don't
want to catch the flu it's probably a
good idea to put your mask on or if
you're not feeling well it's probably a
good idea to put your mask on if you
still have to travel so you don't get
other [ __ ] sick this is not
really complicated about wearing a mask
on an airplane
now it's now it's not mandatory it's
optional
but don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ] don't be
an [ __ ] it's really not that hard and
it's not just airplanes it's trains
buses
if you're not feeling well
wear a mask don't be an [ __ ] if you
don't want to get sick
don't be an [ __ ] just wear a [ __ ]
mask
wear a mask because here's the thing if
you're not an [ __ ] and you're wearing
a mask and then there's people
are you're wearing a mask and you're not
an [ __ ] people are gonna know that
but if you're not wearing a mask people
are gonna wonder
hey is that an [ __ ]
hey look over there jill is that an
[ __ ] looks like an [ __ ] to me
we'll put his mask on to make sure
people don't get sick
what an [ __ ] thank you
thank you mayo for your tweet one of our
favorites here mayo
jordy my zealouses i'm still wearing
masks on an air on airplanes
but only because y'all's breast breast
smells that's not a bad that's not a bad
point
you know if you got bad breath put on a
[ __ ] mask the rest of us the rest of
us will appreciate it
whoosh put on a mask you nasty [ __ ] okay
have you guys seen this video
from mallory mcgraw
representative
from
michigan i want to go through this video
this is a very important video let's see
i got some other video i want to show to
let's see what else do we get i'm almost
done here
um we're going to go to the trendy
trends here soon
yeah let's let's do this video we're 21
minutes into the second hour so let's
let's watch this video real quick
i want to break it down because she says
some really good stuff here
but there's some problems with it it's
an awesome video
janie says from facebook she says it's
an awesome video and it is an awesome
video
but there's real there's problems with
it and i want to point them out
and i want to point out the major
problem with it and it's not the video
it's not a message
that's not the problem but i'll point it
out i'll show you
thank you mr president
i didn't expect to wake up yesterday to
the news that the senator from the 22nd
district had overnight accused me by
name of grooming and sexualizing
children in an email fundraising for
herself
so i sat on it for a while wondering why
me
and then i realized because i am the
biggest threat to your hollow hateful
scheme because you can't claim that you
are targeting marginalized kids in the
name of quote parental rights if another
parent is standing up to say no
so then what then you dehumanize and
marginalize me you say that i'm one of
them you say she's a groomer she
supports pedophilia she wants children
to believe that they were responsible
for slavery and to feel bad about
themselves because they're white
well here's a little bit of background
about who i really am
growing up my family was very active in
our church i sang in the choir my mom
taught ccd one day our priest called a
meeting with my mom and told her that
she was not living up to the church's
expectations and that she was
disappointing
my mom asked why among other reasons she
was told it was because she was divorced
and because the priest didn't see her at
mass every sunday so where was my mom on
sundays she was at the soup kitchen with
me
my mom taught me at a very young age
that christianity and faith was about
being part of a community about
recognizing our privilege and blessings
and doing what we can to be of service
to others especially people who are
marginalized targeted and who had less
often unfairly i learned that service
was far more important than performative
nonsense like being seen in the same pew
every sunday or writing christian in
your twitter bio and using that as a
shield to target and marginalize already
marginalized people i also stand on the
shoulders of people like father ted
hesberg the longtime president of the
university of notre dame who was active
in the civil rights movement who
recognized his power and privilege as a
white man a faith leader and the head of
an influential and well-respected
institution and who saw black people in
this country
being targeted and discriminated against
and beaten and reached out to lock arms
with dr martin luther king jr when he
was alive when it was unpopular and
risky and marching alongside them to say
we've got you
to offer protection and service and
allyship to try to right the wrongs and
fix injustice in the world
so who am i i am a straight white
christian married suburban mom who knows
that the very notion that learning about
slavery or redlining or systemic racism
somehow means that children are being
taught to feel bad or hate themselves
because they are white is absolute
nonsense
no child alive today is responsible for
slavery no one in this room is
responsible for slavery but each and
every single one of us bears
responsibility for writing the next
chapter of history each and every single
one of us decides what happens next and
how we respond to history and the world
around us
we are not responsible for the past we
also cannot change the past we can't
pretend that it didn't happen or deny
people their very right to exist
i am a straight white christian married
suburban mom i want my daughter to know
that she is loved supported and seen for
whoever she becomes i want her to be
curious empathetic and kind
people who are different
are not the reason that our roads are in
bad shape after decades of disinvestment
or the that health care costs are too
high or that teachers are leaving the
profession
i want every child in this state to feel
seen heard and supported not
marginalized and targeted because they
are not straight white and christian
we cannot let hateful people tell you
otherwise to scapegoat and deflect from
the fact that they are not doing
anything to fix the real issues that
impact people's lives
and i know
that hate will only win if people like
me
stand by and let it happen
so i want to be very clear right now
call me whatever you want i hope you
brought in a few dollars i hope it made
you sleep good last night
i know who i am i know what faith and
service means and what it calls for in
this moment
we will not let
hate win
damn
here's the problem with this video let
me let me show you here let me take down
the banner here
let me show you the problem with this
video it ain't what she said
it's that it only has 9.8 million views
and that sounds like a lot that sounds
like a lot like god damn tony jesus
that's a lot 9.8 that's only on this one
post
that's only on this one post
from senator erica geist
of michigan
that one post of this video has
9.8 million views that's not enough
folks
that's not enough
it really isn't that that's not enough
it's not enough
that there's only 9.8 million views on
this post
there should be a hundred million views
on this post
the problem with this is is we all know
this
we all know this we know this i know
this you know this i say it every
[ __ ] day
that they're that they're sexualizing
your children's gender
and they're out to get your kids they're
out to marry them and they're using
they're using their religious dogma to
hide behind their bigotry
that's exactly what mallory is saying
here and she's saying it correctly
but it's not enough use we have to get
this message in front of people
that's the most important thing is we
have to get it in front of the generic
ballot
and i know it always sucks like oh why
do we always have to pander to people
who don't pay attention to politics
because they vote and they have a vote
that's a thing fascist vote in this
country too
fascists have the right to vote they
have rights like that's how it works
that's how liberty works we give
everybody liberty everybody equality
equity in their liberty i mean we're not
there yet we need to keep working at it
but that's the idea is we give everyone
liberty
equality and equity
and in the end in the end democracy will
turn out the best possible product it's
difficult
and it takes a while to get there and
everyone doesn't get everything they
want
every single time that's not how it
works that's not how democracy works
it's actually
the kind of model is not everyone gets
what they want
so it's the betterment for everyone
we have to get this message
in front
of people who are the generic ballot for
2022 because yes this midterm in 2022 is
our most important election
and and and we're gonna say it again
after this election the next one
the next one is the most important
election that's because we have fascists
knocking at the door trying to destroy
our democracy so every single election
rather it be the midterm or your [ __ ]
school board or your county commission
for your goddamn dog catcher for crying
out loud that is the most important
election
for pro-democracy people to be inside
government and actually institute
pro-democracy policies
and not tear down our democracy and [ __ ]
on our constitution and create a fascist
state that steve bannon donald trump
greg abbott ron desantis all the [ __ ]
pedocon republican kid diddlers out
there the fascist state that they want
we have to fight in every single
election and that just does not mean you
going to vote
on the ballot
you have to talk you have to tell people
you have to show them what's at stake
when you're at your church at your
school at your community center at your
[ __ ] grocery store
it is important that you're interacting
in a way
that makes sure people know on social
media
when you're talking to your family
members on the phone when you go to your
family events yeah your uncle daryl's
there and he's an [ __ ] but it doesn't
matter
you have to stand for democracy
you have to
and the way that you do that is to have
a pro-democracy message everywhere
you go
and you can do things to help in
elections you can help a candidate by
door knocking stuffing stuffing
envelopes licking envelopes stamping
them sending postcards making phone
calls sending text messages you can do
all those things one of the most
important thing is to give them a few
dollars here or there that's a real
important thing because all that stuff
costs money
but more importantly than that you have
to get your messaging correct
and you have to be on point with your
messaging and the reason why is because
when you're in front of someone who is
the generic ballot who's gonna vote
against something
republicans know this they're [ __ ]
super good at this
that's why you're always like why are
republicans focused on
sex education in kindergarten when it
doesn't exist because they're trying to
make the generic ballot afraid that the
democrats
want to teach children sex education in
kindergarten
they're trying to scare the generic
ballot because the generic ballot is not
paying attention to these things
of what is actually happening and who
these people actually are do you think
do you think most people in this country
know who the secretary of state is
do you think most the people in this
country even know who the vice president
is
the department of transportation
one of the most important secretaries in
our country is the department of
transportation
our entire economy
our entire consumer economy is reliant
on our transportation system in this
country the entire [ __ ] thing the
whole goddamn [ __ ] and caboodle
is reliant on the transportation system
in this country
and they couldn't even tell you who the
[ __ ] it is
most people that's okay though it's okay
that they can't tell you
because you're not gonna change that
i mean we can't flip a switch and
everyone be educated on government and
civics overnight it's gonna take a
while nancy says yeah pete
go pete
go mayor pete nice secretary pete see
you guys know this you guys know you
know these things because you're [ __ ]
paying attention you're goddamn you're
here on facebook you're here on youtube
you're here on twitch or twitter and
you're listening to me yelling screaming
to a microphone two hours a day
of course you know these things
but that doesn't mean other people know
and the people who need to know are
going to remember this they're going to
vote against
something
they're not going to vote for something
they know people people on the generic
ballot never vote for something
they always vote against
something republicans have understood
this for decades and decades and decades
that's why they always want to have
these wars about these lies of
manufactured crisis
they always want to do this manufacturer
crisis thing and they manufacture this
thing that doesn't exist this scary
[ __ ] thing remember remember now i
guess it was uh probably i don't know
it's been a long time ago when the
scariest thing in the country was crt do
you remember this
manufactured crisis
critical race theory
they couldn't tell you what it was they
didn't know what it was they only knew
that it was racist against white people
and they didn't want it
and it's scary
and it's something to be afraid of
you have you figured it out yet that's
where the gener generic ballot votes
they vote based on their fear of
something that they don't want
republicans are handing us this 2022
midterm
they are setting the proverbial ball up
on the t for us
of all the things that you should be
afraid of are you
you're not afraid of them taking away
your [ __ ] liberty you're you're not
afraid of them telling you what medical
procedures you can and can't have to
save your life
you're not afraid that they're trying to
take the consent away from you for your
children
you're not afraid that they're passing
bills and state legislators to ban math
and public schools you're not afraid
that they're that they're passing bills
to try to marry your children
if you're not afraid of that oh we're
really [ __ ]
we're completely [ __ ]
but i have a feeling that the generic
ballot out there if they know if they
truly know the things that republicans
are trying to do in these legislators
the things the fascist ass [ __ ] that
they want to do to our country the
things they want to tell you you can or
can't do and what who you can and can't
love
what your kids can and can't do and what
consent you have over them and what they
can and can't learn like facts
i guarantee you the generic ballot is
going to be absolutely [ __ ] terrified
terrified of it
alls we have to do
as pro-democracy people is show the
generic ballot that this is what
republicans are doing this is what they
want to do
this is how they want to change our
country
a change you can be afraid of
you want to ch whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
you want to change
but you want to change for the bad well
here's the change for the bad
doubt me go back and look go back and
look at all the republican rhetoric for
the last 40 years
look at their rhetoric
it's always be afraid of them be afraid
of this be afraid of that
you remember you remember
they're coming across the border they
don't send their best
be afraid of brown people build a wall
that's what they said that's what build
a wall means bella wall didn't mean
actually build a wall it meant you
should be afraid of brown people because
they're taking your jobs and they're
murdering your children
and they're bringing drugs in the
country that's that's what they were
saying that's what bill the wall meant
hate brown people because brown people
scary that's what they were saying
lock her up you have to be scared of
hillary clinton being the president
because she's a woman
and a woman just can't handle being a
president you should be terrified of
that
lock her up
lock her up
they're talking about grooming
they're talking about grooming because
they want you to be scared of people
grooming children so they can groom
children because frankly
when they talk about building a wall
locking people up
they're projecting all this
they were projecting everything they
were the crooked ones they were the ones
who couldn't handle being president
they're the ones who can't govern they
don't know how because they have no
policy to govern on
i mean other than marrying children and
banning math books
it really is not that complicated folks
the messaging isn't mallory has showed
you here
the problem is that we need we need more
of this messaging but we need it from
you that's the one thing republicans get
right they're always on the same team
and they got a huge team of people
you can't be scared to say florida is
trying to ban math well really actually
what florida's trying to do is florida's
is trying to ban 54 macbooks from the
curriculum of the publication shut the
[ __ ] up
so now for that [ __ ] enough of
explaining it to the point to where
you're not [ __ ] talking about what we
need to be talking about
they want to ban math in florida
they don't want your kids learning math
it doesn't matter why it doesn't matter
who
doesn't matter how they don't want your
kids to learn math
that's the message
they want to marry your children
that's the message
they're going to take away women's right
to vote
that's the mess that's next
doubt me
wait wait i'm sure during during this
fall session when the fall session
starts right before the midterm they're
going to have bills that restrict the
right of women to vote they're already
restricting the right of black people
and people of color all around
they're targeting the areas where people
of color live
and they're targeting those areas
doubt me
if you're a woman out there and you're
in one of the cheeto dust confederacy
states where they're trying to take your
liberty away from your body you don't
think you don't think they're gonna make
sure that you can't vote for them you
can't vote them out
come on the people who are trying to
take away your [ __ ] liberty are gonna
try to make sure that you can't vote
them out
100
full stop
they're gonna do it
i'm gonna tell you when they do it too
and i'm gonna say remember when i told
you remember when i said here you go
here's the bill here's the evidence that
they don't want women to vote that's
what lock her up means
that's what it means
that's why they're so [ __ ] pissed off
that kamala harris is is the vice
president ain't got nothing to do with
her being black
or a person of color
she's a woman
she'd a woman you think they were really
pissed off that kbj was black not not
not i mean that pissed him off but she
was a woman
that's what pissed him off
pissed them the [ __ ] off
that she and not only was she a woman
she was four women and four women's
rights i mean you get a woman who's
against women's rights ah that woman's
fine and well that's a that's a
perfectly good conservative woman who's
against women's rights like amy coney
barrett when she hides her bigotry
behind her religious dogma that's fine
you get it you get a a representative
like lasko who can't [ __ ] count who's
against who's against women who's
against migrants that's a good
conservative woman when she's against
people of color and she's against women
but when she's when she's for taking
away liberty for marginalized people
she's good with us
because what what conservative women
don't understand when they do this whole
oh i'm for i'm for taking away liberty
for marginalized people is there next
they're taking away their own [ __ ]
rights
my dis margie says like marjah blackburn
absolutely
hondo percento marjorie taylor green
lauren bobert sarah
amy comey coney barrett
the list goes on and on kaylee mcinanny
they're not elected officials but
they've been in government before
and they're trying to get back in
government the fascists are trying to
take over our country they're at the
doorstep folks
and they're here for your freedom
they're here for your rights and they're
here for your liberty because it
threatens their power
and democracy
is not an instrument that they like
because democracy is the enemy of
fascism
if we do it correctly that is
if we do democracy if we do it
incorrectly
then it's then it's the weapon that
fascism uses
just like they did on january 6 they
were trying to weaponize democracy to
tear it down
we see that now on the text messages
jesus christ donald trump jr was saying
oh there's all kinds of methods where we
can overturn this election
all kinds of methods mark meadows was
receiving tons of seditious sex
messaging saying hey hey hey
we can overturn this election
we can use our democracy
to tear it down and make it a fascist
state and have a dictator
wipe our ass with the constitution
and they're willing to weaponize our
democracy they're willing to weaponize
our constitution to tear it apart and
create a fascist state that's their goal
just like they're doing in florida
with anti-trans bills anti-gay bills
their their war against disney [ __ ]
stupid
their absolute obsession obsession with
banning books even math books
in tennessee they're obsessed with
marriage and marrying children
in missouri they're doing the same thing
passing anti-trans
trans children bills in texas in
oklahoma they're stripping away the
entire liberty that women have over
their bodies the whole [ __ ] in caboodle
and you don't think that they're gonna
come for you and come for your vote next
you don't think they're gonna come for
the consent of your children after
they're done with taking away the
consent of of trans children or lgbtq
children you don't think they're gonna
come for your consent of your children
you don't think so
you think they're just gonna stop
that these good christians are just
going to stop
at the consent
of lgbt community communities they're
just going to stop at the autonomy of
women not their vote
they tried
to overthrow
the constitution of the united states
they're still trying to commit a cheeto
dust kangaroo coup
trying to overturn our election that we
had
our vote that we made
in our country they're trying to
overturn
our vote
still to this day
john eastman's running around the
country talking about how that the
alternative slate of electors can is
still a possibility they're still
committing treason they're still
committing crimes they're still trying
to obstruct official proceeding they're
still trying to commit election fraud
still to this day
they want to hearken back to a day
when they could when they could oppress
the marginalized
when it was okay and they don't just
want it to be a social thing they wanna
they wanna enshrine it into law
and no both parties aren't the same
because you get this [ __ ] too oh
democrats aren't doing enough they're
not canceling student debt they're not
giving me this they're not giving me
that they're not doing this they're not
doing that joe manchin christian cinema
blah blah blah blah blah democrats bad
democrats bad
there's only one party in this country
that is pro-democracy at this point
there have been times in our history
where bull parties were pro-democracy
there have been times
now some more than others right
sometimes one party is more democratic
and more pro-democracy than the other
right now we have one party who is for
democracy
who is for continuing the constitution
of the united states and continuing our
form of government
one
one party
the other party is a fascist party
they want to roll back and take away
your liberty
one party wants to expand freedoms of
americans
the other wants to rein it in claw back
and restrict freedoms
of americans choose wisely in the 2020
election is that what you wanted me to
say
the 2022 midterm is upon us it's right
now not tomorrow not next week not next
month because by the time we get to the
2022 midterm these cheeto dust
confederacy states are already going to
pass all these laws
you seen when ian mackey in the state of
missouri
talked on the floor of the of the
missouri legislator about an anti-trans
athlete bill
and he said
he said it
so true he said
you will win this one gentlemen you will
win this fight you will win this bill
you are going to pass this anti-trans
bill in this state and it is disgusting
but you will not win
this battle
we will win
our democracy
because i believe there are more people
out there that are for democracy than
against it
they just they might not know which
party is for democracy and which one's
against it that's why it's up to you
it's up to you
it's up to you and not just going and
voting
when i say go [ __ ] vote i don't just
mean mark a ballot
you got to engage you got to ask these
people questions people who are the
generic ballot people you work with
people you go to church with people
you're at the community center with that
god damn the person in the grocery store
line
you just say oh did you hear florida's
trying to ban math boy that's an easy
that's an easy catch
and we can say that line from now until
the until the end until the midterm
actually we can say that till now until
the end of time republicans are trying
to ban math
republicans are trying to ban math
that's a conversation starter did you
hear republicans are trying to ban math
what
yep
in florida
and fascist governor ron desantis is
banning macbooks from schools
they're not gonna go look it up
they're not
they're not gonna go google it
you don't even have to say it most
people like well go google it here i'll
provide you an article
mr generic voter they don't give a [ __ ]
they're not gonna look it up
they're not not not in between them
scrolling down their facebook page and
looking at the next thing that's on sale
or the next ad that facebook's gonna
press to them or what their friends did
last weekend or what their friends are
gonna do next weekend
or what their favorite reality show what
that was or clip from friends they're
not they're not gonna they're not gonna
pay attention they're not gonna go
google the article
but if everyone everyone's saying that
republican is trying to ban math
i'm like well that must be true
everyone's saying everybody's saying the
last five people i talked to are saying
it
and everyone's saying hey did you hear
they're trying to pass bills where they
can marry your children what
what the [ __ ]
republicans are trying to marry children
you hear this they're trying to pass it
in 14 states
you want to win
you want to make sure we have
a legislator not just in our united
states capital but inside your state
that is pro-democracy
that's going to do things like make sure
you have a decent health care that you
don't go bankrupt over a medical bill
make sure that your kids start school at
three instead of five
make sure you and your kids don't go
broke because they want to go to college
you want you want to make sure you want
to make sure that your roads don't have
potholes
that your bridges aren't going to
collapse out from underneath you
you want to make sure of all that
well it's time to win it's time to fight
and that fight is now and that fight is
on that hill that the republicans want
to die on that fascist hill that they
want to die on because they're giving us
everything we need for messaging and
mallory shows it
mallory shows it to us
it's even in it's even in the walt
disney [ __ ]
they're fighting
they're fighting with mickey mouse folks
because disney is standing up for
people's rights
think about that
they are mad at disney
for standing up for people's
constitutional rights
that's why they're mad at them
and disney is woke
because they're standing up for people's
constitutional rights think about that
we are woke because we stand up for
people constitutional rights i i mean i
consider myself woke then i guess
i mean if that's the definition of woke
if that's the definition
is that we stand up for people's rights
and their liberty well count me the
[ __ ] if that's the case
if that's what it means
i don't think they know what it means
but that's what they're saying
and again the fight is the good fight
i i believe that my audience here is all
pro-democracy even some of the hate
listeners out there are pro-democracy
they believe in democracy they believe
that
in the greater good i believe that i
believe that and most of the people on
the generic ballot believe the same
thing
but we just have to forget this stuff
about you know going and voting for
something they're gonna vote against
something
81 million people didn't vote for joe
biden folks there's a large part portion
of that 81 million that voted against
trumpism
full stop
voted against pumping bleach into people
voted against a lot of the coveted
policies voted against hal kovid not
paying attention to covet [ __ ] up our
economy
voted against not helping of the
american people
only corporations through covid
financially
yeah
that's what people went and voted
against
so don't discount that i'm telling you
it'll work
in the 2022 midterms
we have
we have to get the messaging out there
that the republican kid diddler
petticons
are something to vote against
because they're not just coming
they're not just coming for the lgbtq
community's children and the consent of
their children they're coming after your
consent and they're not just coming
after the liberty and the autonomy of
their of your body they're coming after
your right to vote
they want to tell private corporations
these are supposed free market
capitalists they want to tell private
corporations that they're not allowed to
stand up for for the oppression of other
people they are not allowed to stand up
and speak out against
the state government oppressing the
rights of other people they're not
allowed to do that
they're not allowed to have freedom of
speech
they're not allowed to be woke
whatever the [ __ ] that means
and they want to ban math they want to
ban education
you think they're going to stop at
banning math books
and to kill a mockingbird you think
they're going to stop at taking away
your preschool in college you think
they're going to stop there they're
going to take away high school
you know they talk about grooming it's
all projection they're grooming they're
grooming the entire nation to say well
maybe we don't need public education i
mean we don't need that maybe we don't
need we won't need gay marriage maybe we
don't need women to have rights
they're grooming america
they're grooming you
that's the message get it out there go
shout out from the rooftops i know you
guys will because i'll be shouting every
single weekday monday through friday two
hours
on youtube twitter twitch live
and also now broadcasting from the minus
touch facebook page you can catch the
tony michaels podcast every single
weekday every last one of them noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific go
subscribe to the youtube page please do
me that favor go subscribe to youtube
page make sure you do not miss any
any of the episodes we also put up clips
so if you guys want to re-watch
something we normally put up a clip that
you guys really liked
so go check it out on the youtube page
also download
our episodes on spotify apple google all
your favorite directory leave us a five
star review there
and like us on facebook i i don't i
don't know i i'm i'm not a
i don't know much about the books of
face
i don't know much about the meta
universe but we're over there on the
minus such facebook page so watch us
like us
continue to comment
we're watching you
as much as you're watching us
thank you for joining us today
keep engaged keep out there keep the
messaging going remember all you
pro-democracy people out there that you
are you are the most important part of
this most important election
and what you say and what you do and how
you say it is super important every
single day who you talk to
the way you type it out on social media
the interactions that you have
rather be on the phone in person at your
church at your community center at your
grocery store at your children's school
these interactions are super important
they really are
and it's super important that these
people know the issues that that are at
hand and are going to affect them
so make sure that messaging's on point
because
on mallory's video 9.8 million views
just is not enough
it's not enough
it's not go ever going to be enough only
10 million views on twitter and we need
to get it at least 100 million views and
that's up to you so don't just
send this video to someone
talk to people tell them
knock on doors
help your candidate send postcards make
phone calls send text messages give them
a few bucks give them a few bucks it's
gonna help
and it's gonna make sure that
pro-democracy win this midterm
pro-democracy people win this midterm
that is the most important part for our
democracy and for your liberty
until tomorrow
surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking